these are questions i got from the
center for the future of museums and so
they say for readers who may be
unfamiliar with the khan academy can you
give a capsule description of your work
and i'll make it even clearer it's not
just my work anymore where a team of 15
and growing people actually i think
we're now at 16. and it started off as
essentially it got most known for a
video library that i originally made for
my cousins put them on youtube got
really popular i was doing it as a as a
hobby really i had a day job as a as an
analyst at an investment fund um
i was also working on kind of a
primitive version of software to quiz
them and things like that then in 2009 i
quit my job to work on it full time and
2010 we got funding to work on and so
most of the funding is actually to work
on the software platform and our the
software lets students start at any
place one plus one equals two it'll
generate problems for them and it won't
and allow them to move ahead as they
gain proficiency as they gain mastery of
subjects so they learn at their own pace
and they make sure that all of the gaps
are filled and the videos are there to
complement the exercise platform and
right now there's over 2 700 videos
covering everything from basic
mathematics to calculus to college level
uh you know differential equations
linear algebra and
sciences biology chemistry and a little
bit of history and economics and finance
the exercises are deeper k through 12
math
over the next year we'll see it or we'll
hopefully all see it get to be fairly
deep k through i would say 14 math so
cover a lot of the advanced mathematics
and then beyond that you're going to see
the exercise platform move into physics
and chemistry and even parts of biology
and maybe grammar and things like that
and the whole idea for us as a
not-for-profit is to be
is to be number one a way for anyone
anyone to get an education our mission
is literally a world-class education
anyone anywhere for free so free
free education
free education and number two
is to be a tool that can be leveraged
inside the classroom to make the
classroom more interactive
tool to make the classroom more
interactive
classroom interactive and when i say
this it's a little unintuitive because
we are a technology tool and we involve
on-demand video and we involve
exercises that are done on a computer so
how are you making it more interactive
when i say more interactive i literally
mean interactive with humans and and the
model that we're experimenting with now
and the initial results seem very very
promising in the pilot real classrooms
that we've been dealing with is because
so much of the scaffolding of knowledge
of you know can have the conceptual
development so much of the exercises can
be done on the online platform what
we're saying is take that part outside
of the classroom experience this can be
done at a student's pace at their time
and then give that data to the teacher
and so when the student goes into the
classroom when they go into the
classroom you have all this freed up
time so that the students can teach each
other they're all learning at different
paces and the teacher can do more
focused more deep interventions with the
students because the teachers now have
all of this they now have all of this
data so it frees up time powers a
teacher with data all of class time no
longer one pace fits all one size fits
all lectures it's now all about everyone
working at their own pace and and and
the every minute of a teacher's time and
every minute of a student's time is is
either working at their own pace or
interacting with each other so that's
what we talk about it as a tool and
right now most of the users are right
over here
most of the users right over here we
have about two and a half million unique
students a month and that number is
growing exponentially really
and they've already watched over 70
million videos and they've done over 100
million exercises we have about a
million exercises done per day now and
that number is also extreme
growing rapidly so that's kind of the
general overview of what we're doing and
one thing i want to be clear here is for
both of these for both of these what you
we as
we've only had funding for about 12
months i've been doing this in one form
or another for for five or six years now
or actually closer to seven years but as
an organization we've only been around
for less than a year and so these are
works in progress these are works in
progress we are
we're already seeing good results and
good traction with what we already have
but we we hope to just learn more and
more from the schools
and the teachers and the parents and the
students that we're working with to just
improve them better and better and make
this part make the education and make
the classroom
more and more rich experiences either
through things that we do directly or
through the things that we enable
because we're taking other things off
the table
question number two what do you see as
the greatest barrier technological
cultural political to mainstreaming the
khan academy system into public
education well you know i think the
first is is something that i'll put
firmly on khan academy's shoulders on
our shoulders is that we have to make a
very compelling case and a compelling
case isn't just a cool piece of software
that a lot of people are using or a
bunch of videos that a lot of people are
using that that's part of it and and we
do have traction that traction happened
organically which i think does speak to
it no one forces these two million or
two and a half million students every
month to to use our site they they
themselves find it compelling
but that by itself isn't enough
we need to go into classrooms and we
don't and we i think it's very important
that people understand that we don't
think that we have a perfected solution
we think that we have the start of a
compelling solution but what we want to
do is work with and this is what we're
doing with our pilot classrooms we want
to work with these teachers these
students these parents to make a better
product and see how this product can be
used to see how we can so that we can
fully enter so we can really make the
classroom as human of an experience as
possible and then of course we have to
we have to prove that it works and and
proving that it works is you know
there's one metric that people in the
education or maybe the policy world like
which is performance on test scores we
definitely want to make sure that we
have improvements or at minimum no
negatives and so far it does look like
it's we are seeing actually fairly
dramatic improvements in in in certain
classes uh using this using the model
we're advocating and using these tools
uh but improvement also happens in
intangible ways with kids uh if if now
kids are able to do as good on the test
as they were before or even better on
the tests uh but now they are they have
a better attitude towards mathematics
they have they're more tentative in
class they are um they they they're
they're able to be exposed because you
have all of this freed up class time to
projects and experiences that they
wouldn't have otherwise been exposed to
that can't necessarily be captured on an
assessment exam if those things are
happening we also view that as signs of
success so these are things that we have
to prove
once we do and hopefully we are able to
prove all of those things and it seems
like we are on track hopefully you know
knock on wood to to to do those things
uh then the next thing is to to really
just i think the the main
bottleneck because we are a free
solution we are not for profit people
know that we aren't doing this to make
money off of it we're doing this because
we we generally care about education
is is i think just people to
one understand what we're talking about
so right now there's some knee-jerk
reactions that think that we're about
we're all about kids spending all of
their time on a computer or spending all
their time uh watching videos and that
somehow replaces teachers we're about
the opposite of that we think class time
should be about interaction we think
that we are the catalyst to take
lectures out of the classroom to make
the classroom uh to make the classroom
more interactive so people have to get
over those um i guess
those knee-jerk reactions which which i
think aren't aren't correct uh
perceptions of what we're trying to do
and then beyond that it's just you know
just a willingness to change and i think
the willingness to change uh there are
many really open-minded teachers that
are already doing it and those are the
ones that we're working with to really
help define what we are to help define
what our future should be um and and and
those are going well and and i don't
know what percentage of teachers will
fall into that camp where they will just
they see a good tool and they like it
and it seems that has good results and
it gels with their way of teaching
they'll adopt it um
the last thing i'd like to see the last
thing i want to see is people being
forced to use khan academy so i really
want it to be something that's opted
into because you you could you could
force anyone to use you if you force
someone to use even something that's the
best tool on the planet
and they don't want to use it they can
make it a not so great tool and a not so
great experience so our main concern is
really to show that it's a it's a viable
model it's a good model it has all of
the effects that we want it to have that
it really is improving education both
from an assessment point of view and
from a um from an intangible point of
view
uh and and we offer it free and we give
as much information to teachers and
policymakers and and and and parents so
that
their own schools can adopt it if they
want to all of our tools are already
available for free all the tools that
our pilots are using any classroom can
use today and then and then just see see
what happens i guess is the simple
answer
next question currently khan academy
content is heavy on subjects that focus
on on facts and absolutes math chemistry
physics is that mostly a function of
your background and expertise or
inherent in the format what are the
limitations with your current model for
covering squishy topics like art
literature that are more about
aesthetics and interpretation well i i
would say
it is true we are covering math
chemistry physics and sometimes they're
not as fact or absolute based as
sometimes people perceive them to be
but with that said
i've also started making videos on
history and economics and although his
economics is often considered a science
it is also it is it can be a squishy
subject where uh aesthetics and
interpretation do begin to matter one
thing that you will see and i think this
is very interesting for the audience of
of for the future of museums is you will
start to see we are bringing some people
on board in the very near future on art
history
they've already made some really
tremendous videos and i i i will make
the formal announcement once we have
everything integrated
and and they've done a really good job
with art history and they've had these
interesting conversations about it and
um
and i think that's actually a good model
not just for art history but it has it's
a good model for for a lot of the
humanities in something like history or
you know whatever humanity you want to
pick it's nice to have a scaffold even
in art history you won't have a scaffold
you want to know what it means to be to
be a
a surreal painter or what it means to be
or what when did the when did the
baroque period take place or whatever it
might be but and so that's where kind of
maybe more traditional khan academy
style videos are useful to get you the
scaffold of information but then i think
the conversation type style which these
these professors have have kind of
pioneered it's really interesting to get
multiple viewpoints and even if they
don't cover all of the multiple
viewpoints it'll it kind of gives the
student the freedom to realize that you
can have multiple viewpoints and that
they they themselves can form their own
so you're going to see a lot more of
that in the near future so that's on the
video side on the exercise side i think
once again we can start to develop
exercises that help at least make sure
you have the scaffold of information you
know where the civil war fit into the
scope of u.s history you know where the
magna carta what the magna carta even
was and where and how it relates to
other documents and then once you have
that scaffold you're prepared to to
participate in a deeper discussion in
class or a deeper project or a deeper
type of simulation in class next
question
can the khan academy models that
currently works help kid
go from learning facts and operations to
critical reasoning or does that require
a different model
i'd actually say that we are actually
this is what we're about we are about
that right now i think the problem with
a lot of textbooks and some classes is
that they are focused too much on facts
and operations and if
if you look at really any of the khan
academy math videos
sometimes the facts and operations are
shown but they're never shown devoid of
the motivation for doing that fact and
an operation they're never devoid of the
conceptual understanding why it makes
intuitive sense how you can critically
deduce that you can reason those facts
and operations just by thinking about
the problem in the right way and how
multiple problems in different fields
actually reduce to the same core
distilled problem and so i actually
think that right now khan academy is all
about critical reasoning especially on
the video side i think on the exercise
there's a lot more work we have to do
and but we do want to get there so that
we do
expose students some more simulations
more projects more kind of things that
require more than just knowing the steps
of how to do a problem so this is i
think in the videos we're already doing
this to a large degree and frankly i
think that's why khan academy videos
have gotten popular on the exercises
we're starting with the base scaffold
right now and right now the exercises
are more in this direction but i think
over time you're going to see more and
more exercises that point to critical
reasoning simulations things where
you're going to have to manipulate kind
of virtual manipulatives to get to some
type of a goal
next question
25 years from now what do you think a
school day will be like for an
eight-year-old kid in america will she
be commuting to a physical classroom or
accessing content from home how will she
study who will her teachers be and what
will there be the role so i'll answer
the first question ideally they will
they will be going to a physical
classroom
they might if they're in a very rural
place or they don't have access they
they might be able to learn accessing
content from home but i think and i
think we at the organization think that
that physical interaction with other
people is is a huge part of just kind of
becoming kind of maturing and and so we
hope that there's a physical classroom
we think it might be a very different
type of physical classroom um i kind of
imagine now that every student can work
at their own pace
it you don't have to separate kids by
age group anymore and then you can the
benefits of kids helping each other so i
would imagine one really large room
or maybe several really large rooms that
instead of having 30 kids in that room
maybe you have 200 kids in that room but
obviously instead of having one teacher
you have maybe so 200 kids and you know
you obviously want to have as many
teachers as possible the lower the
student-to-teacher ratio the better so
maybe you have i don't know maybe you
have
uh well you could say n teachers but you
know if you have a 25 to one ratio you
would have eight teachers here
you would have eight teachers here and i
think that's about consistent with with
many public schools and so every student
would be working at their own pace for
some part of the day in every subject
all the way from grammar to history to
mathematics the teachers are there to
mentor them to guide them to help them
get past hurdles and because
so much of the learning can hopefully be
done in a very efficient way most of the
day
most of the day is spent doing projects
so if this is the school day we want
maybe this part
is core skills
core skills and the rest of the day is
projects
the rest of the day is projects so kids
writing software kids conducting
scientific experiments real scientific
experiments kids um producing video
content or web pages or blogs or
newspapers or composing music or or or
writing uh short stories whatever it is
they're doing projects and the main role
of the teachers will then be not only to
to help kids get past their hurdles with
the core skills so that the kids can
still perform on these other external
exams and all the rest but also to be
the mentor for the projects and we see
not just the teachers being the mentors
for these for both of these parts we see
the students mentoring each other so if
you have kids of all different age
groups
together then you can have students who
are more advanced or who have a knack
for it to mentor students who are less
advanced
or or who need help in a specific domain
and and we'd like to see the eventual
real powerful transcript and this is
something we already take to heart when
we're hiring people it's nice if you
went to a fancy school with a fancy gpa
with fancy standardized test scores but
what we really care about is what have
you built before what have you starting
with a blank slate
have you ever put your ideas into action
have you ever built anything and so we
think that the resume of the future will
really be the projects
will be the projects that you work on
over the course of your over the course
of your school years both in k-12 and
college and frankly i think that
division between k-12 and college will
also start to get blurred
last question
you've said your goal is to create tens
of thousands of videos in pretty much
every subject and the world's first free
world-class virtual school where anyone
can learn anything can you suggest ways
that museums or museum practitioners
could contribute to khan academy
well i think there's a
there's well they i i encourage museums
for museum practitioners to both make
content and i think some of the art
history content you'll see from us in
the near future will give a very good
idea of how to make that type of content
so one to make content and maybe share
it with khan academy maybe make it part
of the khan academy library and we're
hoping to build tools so that other
people can contribute to the library
in some way
i think the other possibility is to
leverage khan academy material or khan
academy like material so if you have an
installation
or you have a painting on something
instead of having a little placard next
to the thing that talks you know has a
you know 100 word description of it why
not have an explanation of it why not
have someone maybe khan academy style
explaining what that painting is all
about maybe using maybe using some of
our videos that you're about to see in
the next few months on art history
why not have why not have uh uh people
contribute their own interpretations of
the art maybe done khan academy style or
maybe it's just an audio track
i think it it lends itself to a very
interesting question which is what where
are museums going and i think they're
similar to schools in that before you
had to have a physical location to have
a school similarly you had to have a
physical location to have a museum i
think where museums are going to go is
that they're going to turn into these
amazing i mean most museums i know of
amazing physical spaces architectural
spaces community spaces and i think
they'll always be there and i think
there'll always be a role for those
physical spaces but i think i think what
will happen is that the content in those
physical spaces will be much more
dynamic they won't just be this
installation that sits there for three
months or six months or a year
there'll be
information and installations that that
almost change based on the interactions
with the people who visit the
installations and a lot of that static
content the paintings or the
installations those can also be
virtualized so sure if someone goes to
the physical museum that's obviously the
best experience but if you virtualize
them in the right way you can also then
bring the museum experience to people
who don't have the privilege of going to
the museum and i think the google art
project starts to hint at some of this
and if you have the google art project
which gives us very high resolution
pictures of art that one can zoom into
and you couple it with kind of a
conversational commentary on on art
history or on the on the art itself i
think you start to get close to that
that type of experience